à votre avis qu'est-ce qui est vert et
marron et qui plane au dessus des Alpes
non non on ne parle pas de la fille
cachée de Hulk et de la vache Milka qui
ferait un petit tour en tyrolienne on
parle de parcelle de terrain gigantesque
que des chercheurs déplacent en hélico à
travers les montagnes pour étudier les
effets du réchauffement climatique vous
êtes intrigué je parie bah si vous
l'êtes pas c'est que votre omelette aux
champignons ne contenait pas que des
cèpes parce que objectivement des
alpages qui voyagent dans les airs c'est
un petit peu surprenant et très
instructif aussi vous allez voir
[Musique]
bienvenue dans les Alpes juste à côté du
jardin du Lautaret ce lieu a été créé en
1899 pour devenir une réserve de
biodiversité botanique aujourd'hui il
abrite plus de 2000 espèces de plantes
d'altitude et c'est absolument sublime
bon surtout quand les plantes ne sont
pas en hibernation mais bref c'est
sublime et puis nous on était surtout là
pour la science
[Musique]
dans les installations scientifiques de
la station des chercheurs du monde
entier se pressent pour profiter de la
présence de près d'un quart de la flore
française et de la diversité des types
de reliefs et zones climatiques ici les
scientifiques étudient l'adaptation des
organismes à haute altitude mais aussi
le fonctionnement des écosystèmes alpin
ou encore le manteau neigeux grâce à des
dispositifs expérimentaux de pointes
dessert des stations de mesure et des
équipes qui connaissent les montagnes
comme les poches de leur pantalon de
terrain
et c'est ici en 2016 qui est donc né le
projet alpage volant qui porte bien son
nom puisqu'il s'agit de déplacer des
prairies par voie aériennes pour les
emmener vers des zones plus chaudes ici
les chercheurs simulent un réchauffement
climatique de 3 degrés sur les prairies
de montagne pour mesurer l'impact de la
hausse de température sur la flore la
faune et la composition des sols
et pour ça ils ont donc grimpé d'abord
en 2016 puis en 2021 à 2500 mètres
d'altitude pour y découper des parcelles
de terre pesant 120 kilos chacune ils
les ont ensuite attachés à des
hélicoptères avant de les déplacer 500
mètres plus bas là où il fait donc 3
degrés de plus un taf assez banal quoi
jusqu'ici ce sont 10 parcelles de
prairies alpine 2 4 mètres carrés qui
ont été déplacés mais on surveille
également des prairies de contrôle qui
restent bien au frais le but est bien
évidemment d'étudier les différences
entre celles qui sont restées en haut et
celles qui ont fait un petit tour en
hélico
car oui le réchauffement climatique ce
n'est pas juste une histoire de
température c'est aussi et surtout une
transformation en profondeur de tous les
écosystèmes ce qui suppose une
adaptation éclair de tous ceux qui ne
veulent pas mourir spoiler c'est pas
gagné pour tout le monde
depuis la migration des parcelles des
prélèvements sont effectués plusieurs
fois par an par les chercheurs qui
étudient de près les plantes mais aussi
les petites bêtes qui peuplent les
alpages concrètement comment
procède-t-on non parce que vous imaginez
bien qu'on va pas compter les lombrics
ou les micro-champignons à l'œil nu
evidemment pour savoir parmi les espèces
présentes qui s'épanouit malgré le
réchauffement et qui morfle sa petite
maman en short à la montagne on traque
la présence de leurs ADN dans les sols
comme vous le savez chaque espèce
animale ou végétale présente une
signature génétique unique un genre de
code-barre d'identification
ce travail s'apparente un petit peu à
celui de la police scientifique il
s'appuie sur une technique de pointe
baptisée métabares coding moléculaire ou
Diana pour ceux qui veulent cela péter
un petit peu pour trouver le matériel
génétique on procède des carottages
minutieux à l'intérieur des parcelles en
stérilisant au préalable les instruments
pour ne pas introduire d’adn extérieur
et risquer de publier un article
montrant que les populations de
Jean-Marc et Sylvie ont cru
exponentiellement en quelques années et
avec ces échantillons on passe au labo
on mélange les sols prélevés à une
solution tampon à base de phosphate
qu'on agite vivement pendant 15 minutes
pour séparer l'ADN des particules du sol
et le récupérer mais à ce stade c'est un
peu comme si on avait prélevé de la boue
à Verdun dans l'espoir d'identifier un
soldat tout est mélangé et on a des ADN
de toutes les espèces passées par là il
faut donc affiner un peu on passe le
tout à la centrifugeuse à 12000 tours
minute avant de mettre un réactif sur
lequel l'ADN vient se coller puis trois
petits lavages plus tard l'ADN est prêt
à être analysé enfin presque car avant
de lire l'ADN il faut l'amplifier grâce
à la PCR oui oui la même technique
utilisée pour savoir si votre nez est
rempli de covideur on peut alors
distinguer grâce aux séquençage tous les
ADN qui ont été récoltés et identifiez
toutes les espèces présentes dans le
milieu
grâce à cela on peut donc voir année
après année et parcelle par parcelle
quels sont les espèces de plantes
d'animaux microscopiques deux
champignons ou de bactéries dont la
présence s'accroît sous l'effet du
réchauffement et au contraire quels sont
celles qui ont pâtissent le plus sachant
que chaque espèce joue un rôle précis au
sein de l'écosystème où elle évolue donc
ces changements à l'échelle
microscopique ont bien sûr des
conséquences importantes sur la
composition des sols et à terme sur la
biodiversité des reliefs alpins et
d'ailleurs on constate d'ores et déjà 6
ans après le début de l'expérience qui
pourrait durer jusqu'à 15 ans que
certaines espèces perdent la compétition
face à d'autres qui s'adapte mieux au
réchauffement puisqu’on ne retrouve pas
les mêmes espèces au sein des parcelles
situées en haut et en bas des flancs de
montagne plus globalement lorsque l'on
réchauffe les plantes on constate que
leur cycle de vie change leur floraison
leur croissance sont modifiées par
exemple rares sont les espèces qui
s'acclimatent à leur nouvelle condition
de vie plus chaude et à ce jeu là les
grandes gagnantes sont les graminées
pour le plus grand bonheur des
allergiques les plantes à fleurs
orgraminées par contre ne s'acclimatent
pas ce qui engendre une baisse du nombre
et de la diversité des espèces
pollinisatrices à terme ça veut dire
plus de rhinite allergique mais moins de
miel pour les soigner on observe aussi
que la microfaune du sol évolue en
particulier les bactéries qui se
multiplient ce sont des actrices
majeures de la réponse des écosystèmes
au réchauffement alors ce n'est pas
juste par voyeurisme qu'on s'y intéresse
là aussi des espèces disparaissent et
sont remplacées avec des conséquences
sur le fonctionnement des écosystèmes
comme la décomposition de la litière
l'approvision nutriments et bien sûr la
pollinisation et ses effets sont bien
entendu cumulatif si par exemple à
l'avenir comme on s'y attend la neige
devait se raréfier l'hiver les plantes
pérenne souffriraient paradoxalement
davantage du froid parce que la neige
forme un manteau isolant qui les protège
des températures les plus extrêmes
surtout au début du printemps et à la
fin de l'automne bon vous l'aurez
compris une fois de plus la situation
est pas franchement idéale et les
perspectives non plus mais c'est grâce à
ce genre d'expérience un peu folle et
super cool qu'on peut mieux comprendre
les menaces qui pèsent sur ces paysages
millénaires et tenter au moins de les
minimiser on peut donc vraiment dire
merci à nos génies des alpages qui
veillent sur nos montagnes là-haut entre
les sommets enneigés
[Musique]